Je suis très content de pouvoir reprendre cette série d'études.
Et comme on a passé un petit moment éloigné de la lettre des Galates,
on s'est arrêté dans la considération des œuvres de la chair.
Donc c'est important de reprendre un peu les contextes de la lettre
et du chapitre, du passage plus large,
avant de continuer à étudier ce que l'apôtre Paul est en train de nous enseigner.
Donc nous savons qu'à plusieurs égards, la lettre des Galates est l'une des plus importantes.
Bien sûr, quand il s'agit de la parole de Dieu,
chaque lettre, chaque particule trouvée dans la Bible est inspirée.
Donc elle a dans un sens une égalité d'importance générale.
Mais c'est clair aussi que par rapport au contenu que nous trouvons dans la Bible,
il y a certaines portions où les vérités principales d'Évangile
ressortent avec plus de clarté, avec plus d'importance.
Et à plusieurs égards, la lettre aux Galates,
elle est l'une des lettres les plus importantes pour ce qui concerne
la compréhension de la distinction entre les rôles du judaïsme,
qui avait un rôle légitime, temporaire et temporel,
à jouer envers notre salut,
les Messies des vrais venirs des Juifs,
et la compréhension que le christianisme est quelque chose qui est avant le judaïsme
et quelque part après le judaïsme, au-dessus du judaïsme,
même si la partie légitime telle qui est dessinée par Dieu à travers le judaïsme
avait un rôle important à jouer.
Et donc là, en plusieurs parlant,
la lettre aux Galates est la lettre des libertés,
car elle va marquer une espèce d'indépendance,
une espèce de déconnexion,
même si cette portion du judaïsme reste connectée à l'Évangile,
c'est une compréhension que l'Évangile est plus grand,
il a son indépendance.
Donc cette dispute, elle devient très claire,
car dans cette église que l'apôtre Paul lui-même a implantée,
l'église des Galates, de la région de la Galatie,
est une église qui était majoritairement païenne.
Donc il n'avait pas un arrière-plan judaïque.
Lorsque Paul allait visiter cette église,
il n'était pas très préoccupé à les enseigner toutes les traditions aux pratiques juives.
L'apôtre Paul, il est venu, il a prêché,
il a prêché Christ et Christ crucifié.
Et cela a été suffisant.
Car dans un certain sens, comme Paul explique dans la lettre,
tous les travaux que Dieu a fait à travers sa relation temporelle avec Israël,
c'était pour créer des conceptions didatiques envers la compréhension de l'absolu besoin d'un Messie,
d'un représentant de toute la race humaine,
car la promesse a été faite d'abord à Abraham,
d'abord à Adam même,
le représentant de toute la race,
ensuite à Abraham,
avant qu'il ait des enfants,
avant que le judaïsme soit là,
avant la circoncision.
Et cette promesse de Dieu,
c'était que toutes les nations seraient bénies dans son descendant.
Les descendants, comme Paul va montrer à Christ,
et une fois qu'il est Christ,
vient et qu'il est l'accomplissement et la clarification
de tous ceux qui l'Ancien Testament,
et notamment toute l'histoire judaïque,
et les lois cérémoniales par exemple,
voulaient représenter,
une fois qu'on est devant les soleils,
pour plus que les soleils puissent nous donner encore plus d'éclarité
par rapport à toutes ces ombres de l'Ancien Testament,
on n'a pas forcément besoin des ombres une fois qu'on a le soleil.
Et donc, ils étaient des vrais enfants de Dieu, les Galates,
convaincus de leur salut,
en pleine assurance de la foi,
avec la capacité de manifester les Christ en eux,
indépendamment de leur connaissance
de la loi mosaïque.
Car ils avaient Christ,
ils avaient le Saint-Esprit de Dieu,
et les fruits de l'Esprit se manifestaient dans les rues.
À un moment donné, Paul doit dire aux Galates,
« Vous aviez bien commencé ».
Sauf qu'il y a eu une interférence dans la vie de cette Église.
Donc, Paul continue à faire ses travaux missionnaires,
il part,
et les judaïsens arrivent.
C'était des soi-disant chrétiens,
qui disaient croire que les Christ étaient nécessaires pour les saluts,
mais qui, au même temps,
gardaient
cette sensation d'être plus importants,
car ils étaient la vraie descendance des Juifs.
Il y avait une attitude nationaliste,
ethnique,
et une volonté de s'approprier quelque part
de cette communauté.
Et eux, ils avaient plein de stratégies différentes
pour apporter
ce qui était leur thèse.
D'un côté, ce qu'ils disaient, c'est,
« Oui, Christ est nécessaire
pour que nous soyons déclarés justes devant Dieu »,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que les fils de Dieu,
en représentant véritablement Dieu et humain,
vivent parfaitement la loi à notre place,
soient morts à la croix à cause de nos péchés,
et que par la foi,
en étant associés à Christ,
c'est-à-dire en choisissant par la foi
d'embrasser Christ comme notre représentant légal devant Dieu,
lorsque Dieu nous contemple,
il nous regarde devant son tribunal,
il ne considère pas
nos fautes, nos transgressions,
nos mérites ou nos performances.
Dieu considère tout simplement
si ton représentant légal est Christ,
sa perfection de vie t'est crédité,
et ta coupabilité a été crédité à Christ à la croix,
donc il a payé la double dette,
obéissance parfaite à la loi à votre place,
et il est mort à la croix à votre place.
Donc Dieu ne peut pas te traiter désormais
comme s'il y avait encore une dette,
comme si tu méritais autre chose
qu'il sait qui a déjà été payé par Christ,
et ce que Christ a mérité,
être traité comme un enfant par exemple,
avec une demande de la part de Dieu
complètement satisfaite
pour ce qui concerne notre obéissance.
Donc ils étaient d'accord en partie
que pour ce qui concerne les pardons de nos péchés
et d'être déclarés justes devant Dieu,
ils avaient besoin du Christ.
Même les juifs savaient,
les juifs convertis,
ou les soi-disant juifs chrétiens,
ils savaient que c'était impossible
d'accomplir à la loi
et qu'ils avaient besoin du Christ.
Sauf qu'à partir du moment
où ils mettaient une nouvelle emphase,
et quelle était cette emphase
auquel Christ est venu,
mais c'est clair qu'il nous a donné
une nouvelle puissance,
mais nous devons maintenir
cette condition de sauver
ou réconcilier avec Dieu
par notre performance religieuse.
Donc ils ont fait la confusion
entre les rôles réels
de toutes les lois et pratiques
et traditions sérémonielles
de l'Ancien Testament,
qui étaient en rappel constant
que notre obéissance
n'était jamais à la hauteur,
qu'on était condamnés
par notre transition
et on appliquait
toutes les cérémonies
des sacrifices
avec le but de nous préparer
pour atteindre
les vrais sacrifices
qui viendraient.
Sauf que pour les juifs,
cette pratique des vies
est devenue quelque chose
d'identitaire,
ils n'arrivaient pas
à comprendre
la sanctification
ou la maintenance du salut
ou la permanence dans la foi
d'une autre manière
qui ne soit
par l'observation de la loi.
Donc,
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent aux Galates ?
Ok,
vous êtes
quelque part frère
mais plutôt cousin.
Car avec
toutes vos pratiques
et votre style de vie
et votre
habitude
païenne,
vos sociétés
ne sauraient pas
garder
et une performance
religieuse
qui puisse contribuer
à votre progression
en santé
ou
maintenir votre salut.
Donc,
vous devez adopter
les principales pratiques
juives.
Vous devez,
à partir de là,
trois choses principales,
vous faire circoncire,
garder
certaines dates
du calendrier
juif
et
ne pas manger
certaines choses.
et donc,
il voulait
que les païens
véritablement convertis,
qu'à plusieurs reprises
démontraient un changement
de vie,
une vie beaucoup plus belle
qui est la vie
de ces soi-disant
juifs convertis,
qu'ils s'accordent
à leur performance
religieuse
en mettant toute l'emphase
sur les faits
qu'on peut avoir besoin
de Christ pour être sauvé
mais pour nous maintenir
dans les saluts
et pour progresser
en santé,
ça dépend de nos efforts
dans la direction
de la loi.
Et donc,
Paul,
il va traiter
cette problématique
par deux
implications principales.
Même si nous déclarons
d'un côté
que Christ est nécessaire
pour les points
de départ
de la foi
mais qu'en même temps
on déclare
que pour nous maintenir
dans la foi,
nous sommes
dans la dépendance
de nos propres efforts,
donc si la perte
du salut
est une possibilité,
ça veut suggérer
que la capacité
de se maintenir
dans les saluts
ou de se faire
sauver
est aussi
une possibilité.
Quelle est la logique
de l'apôtre Paul ?
Pour plus
qu'il vous disait
que Christ était
important
ou nécessaire
pour être sauvé,
à partir du moment
où vous suggérez
que par vos efforts
vous avez la capacité
de maintenir la loi,
si vous pourriez
maintenir
par un seul instant
de manière légitime
les moindres commandements,
ça veut dire
que vous auriez pu
maintenir
tous les commandements.
Et si c'est possible
à l'homme
de maintenir
par ses efforts
les moindres commandements,
ce n'est pas nécessaire
que Dieu envoie
son fils
pour mourir la croix.
Et donc,
ce qu'il peut
l'inconner dire,
c'est que même
si les discours,
comme c'est
les discours catholiques,
vont nous dire
que Christ
est nécessaire
pour les saluts,
mais vos efforts
sont vraiment nécessaires
pour vous maintenir
dans les saluts
ou progresser
dans les saluts,
c'est presque
la même chose
que de dire
Christ n'est pas
forcément nécessaire
pour les saluts.
Si Christ
n'était pas absolument
nécessaire
pour les saluts
et si l'œuvre
du Christ
n'était pas
pleinement efficace
pour sauver,
c'est clair
que selon
les raisonnements
d'un Dieu
en fin du message,
il n'allait pas envoyer
son fils
pour risquer
de sauver certains
et qu'ils se perdent
après.
Car là,
on est devant
la possibilité
que tous se perdent
si les moindres
peuvent se perdre
et l'autorité,
on est dans la possibilité
de l'être humain
de se sauver
toute seule.
Et qu'est-ce
que Paul va dire
devant ça ?
Je n'annule pas
la grâce
de Dieu
car si la justice
est obtenue
par la loi,
Christ est mort
en vain.
Et le problème
n'était pas
tout simplement
légaliste,
ce que je viens
de présenter,
mais c'était aussi
un problème
qu'on appelle
nomiste.
Donc là,
il y a une implication
de l'Erin-Faï
sur l'importance
des performances
religieuses
pour se sanctifier
et maintenir le salut,
mais de l'autre côté,
il y a aussi
cette mentalité
qui nous dit
que pour progresser
en santé,
pour nous maintenir
il faut les faire
par des efforts.
Donc la reproduction
de nos jours
dans les mondes évangéliques,
c'est de retourner
au joug de la loi,
avoir une idée
d'un Dieu toujours
contre nous
avec des menaces
terrifiantes
et c'est ça
qui nous pousse
à chercher
à nous sanctifier.
Une observation
externe de la loi
en gardant des dates
encore,
en faisant des campagnes
des 70 semaines
et si on rate,
on a tout perdu,
en ayant l'impression
que nous ne sommes
pas devant un père
qui ne peut pas
supprimer une fois
qu'il s'est fait père
et qu'il a fait
de nous des enfants,
il ne peut pas
supprimer sa paternité
ni notre filiation.
Et là,
Paul va dire
vous avez une attitude
envers Dieu
qui est plutôt similaire
à celle d'un esclave.
Comme si vous étiez
tous les temps
devant Dieu
en colère
sous une atmosphère
terrifiante
lorsque Dieu
vous a fait
enfant parfaitement
en Christ.
Et donc,
Paul,
en Galate,
il est en train
de porter
ces concepts
de la lettre
de la liberté
qui fait la distinction
entre le judaïsme
et le christianisme,
entre le christianisme
et toute religion
légaliste
ou nomiste.
Mais Paul est surtout
et avant tout
en train de décrire
ce qui,
pour chaque chrétien individuel,
devient
la doctrine
la plus
importante
et la plus
réconfortante
efficace
pour les saluts
et aussi
pour la sanctification
du chrétien.
Donc,
il va travailler
dans deux fronts principaux
la plupart des chapitres
qui vont traiter
la question
d'être sauvé
qui est
par la foi
en Jésus
indépendamment
des œuvres
de la loi
et de l'autre côté,
il va traiter
la doctrine
de la sanctification.
Donc,
si nous lisons
le verset 13,
il dit
frère,
vous êtes appelés
ou vous avez été appelés
à la liberté.
Donc,
la liberté,
dans quel sens ?
Dans tous les sens
dont je vous ai parlé,
la liberté
des menaces
de la loi,
la liberté
d'une vie légaliste,
d'une vie
qui est serrée
fatalement
à la culpabilité
constante
car nous étions
incapables
de satisfaire
les démons
de la loi.
Donc,
on a été affranchis
de la loi.
Mais,
ils étaient très ruses,
les judaïsants,
et ils disaient,
ok,
vous avez été affranchis
de la loi
par Christ,
mais si vous avez été
affranchis de la loi,
comment vous allez
continuer à vous sanctifier
sans la loi,
par exemple ?
Et donc,
l'accusation
qu'ils présentent,
c'est celle-ci
qu'on va trouver
au verset 13 encore.
Vous avez été appelé
à la liberté,
seulement ne faites pas
de cette liberté
en prétexte
de vivre
selon la chair.
Donc,
la stratégie
des judaïsants,
c'était d'abord
de mettre en question
l'authenticité
de l'apostolat d'Épaule
en suggérant
que l'idée d'Épaule
était contraire
à l'idée
des pierres
ou des apôtres
de Jérusalem
en réclamant
eux-mêmes
une autorité apostolique.
Ce sont des choses
qu'on voit
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
les faux prophètes
les plus légalistes
réclament être
des apôtres.
Sauf qu'il n'y a plus
d'apôtres,
il n'y a qu'il y a
les apôtres
qu'on trouve
dans le Votessalon.
Ensuite,
on voit comment
il a attaqué aussi.
Voilà,
ils ont accusé
Paul d'une espèce
d'incohérence.
Et Paul dit,
oui, bien sûr,
j'étais très zélé
pour la loi
avant ma conversion.
Mais après ma conversion,
c'était plus jamais
comme ça.
Et ici,
dans ces passages,
il est en train
d'accuser
la doctrine principale,
la doctrine
de la justification
par la foi seule.
C'est la doctrine principale
qui concerne l'Évangile
et c'est la doctrine
principale
qui Paul va défendre
dans la plupart
des Galates.
Donc là,
je vous ai présenté
un peu la doctrine,
elle dit le suivant,
je suis déclaré
juste devant
les tribunaux
des dieux
par les mérites
du Christ.
Sa durature
m'a été amputée.
Dieu l'a considérée
comme si elle était
la même car,
par la foi,
je l'ai embrassée
comme s'il était
mon représentant légal.
C'est clair ?
C'est ça la justification
par la foi.
Il ne nous manque rien,
il n'y a aucune demande
de la part des dieux.
Nos péchés passés
présents futurs,
les Christ a payé
pour tous à la croix.
Et il a vécu
une vie si parfaite
qui nous qualifie
pour être traité
devant Dieu
par ses mérites.
Ça, c'est la doctrine
de la justification
par la foi
dans sa compréhension
plus réduite.
Sauf qu'en Galate,
Paul, il va dire
qu'il n'y a pas
de séparation
entre la conception
de la déclaration légale
devant les tribunales
des dieux
où les mérites
du Christ
mais sont amputés
et l'objectif
des dieux
à travers
cette déclaration.
Quel est l'objectif
des dieux
lorsqu'ils décident
pardonner
les chrétiens ?
Quel est l'objectif
du chrétien
lorsqu'il veut
s'approcher des dieux
par la foi
et être pardonné
par Dieu ?
C'est une réconciliation
avec Dieu
pour devenir
son enfant,
pour être juste.
Donc, nous n'avons pas
qu'il y ait,
les vrais chrétiens
n'ont pas qu'il y ait
besoin de la justice
du Christ
tout simplement
pour être débarrassé
de l'enfer.
Les vrais chrétiens,
ils ont reçu
une attirance,
un attrait
envers Dieu
où ils désirent
être en communion
avec Dieu.
Quel est le but
d'être pardonné
de l'enfer ?
Si l'une des conceptions
les plus terribles
de l'enfer,
c'est tout simplement
la privation
de la communion
douce avec Dieu.
Pourquoi Christ
à la croix
lorsqu'il va afficher
les pires
par rapport à l'enfer
qu'il est en train
de souffrir
à notre place,
va dire
mon Dieu,
pourquoi m'as-tu
abandonné ?
Ce qui est le plus
terrifiant
à propos de l'enfer
n'est pas tout simplement
les souffrances
qu'on va subir.
C'est notamment
la privation
de la béatitude suprême,
la communion avec Dieu.
Et les vrais chrétiens,
ils veulent non seulement
être avec Dieu,
les chrétiens veulent être
comme Dieu.
Donc par la foi,
on veut s'associer
à la justice du Christ
non seulement
pour être pardonné
ou pour vivre
tout simplement
sur la base
de ses crédits.
Et donc Paul
va développer
la conception
qui est la justification.
Elle a deux compléments.
L'une qui est
dans la théologie
systématique
plus précise
et liée
à la déclaration légale
et l'autre
qui concerne
la transformation
vitale.
Lorsque nous sommes
unis à Christ
par la foi,
nous ne sommes pas
en train de nous unir
à lui
comme un représentant
légal.
Ce n'est pas
qu'une démarche
légale
forensique.
Nous sommes
devant
une union
vitale.
Nous sommes
unis à Christ
car nous sommes
morts pour nous-mêmes.
Nous sommes
régénérés par l'esprit
et cette régénération
dans l'esprit
c'est d'être
mort pour nous
pour être vivant
pour Dieu.
Et cette nouvelle nature
elle représente
l'autre aspect
de la justification.
Donc la justification
elle a un élément
qu'on déclare
comme en étant
l'amputation
ou être déclaré
juste
par une amputation
légale
mais aussi
être rendu
juste
par une infusion
vitale.
Le Saint-Esprit
est infusé
en nous.
Une nouvelle vie
est infusée
en nous.
Nous sommes
transformés
dans l'essence
dans les centres
ou la source
de l'être
et à partir
de là
nous allons
progresser.
La distinction
c'est que
la déclaration
c'est d'une fois
pour toutes
basée sur
les mérites du Christ.
Par contre
la sanctification
ou cette manière
dont Dieu
va nous rendre
juste
est une progression
vitale
et irrésistible.
Si quelqu'un
est véritablement
né de nouveau
et qu'il est
devenu
habitation
du Saint-Esprit
c'est inévitable
qu'il progresse
envers la sainteté.
Et donc
lorsqu'il peut
les dévendre
cette accusation
quelle est l'accusation ?
Donc n'utilisez pas
de votre liberté
comme prétexte
pour vivre
selon la chair
c'est une problématique
qu'on vit encore
aujourd'hui.
Lorsque les personnes
nous disent
si vous insistez
qu'on est pardonné
d'une fois pour toutes
qu'est-ce qui va
motiver les personnes
à se sanctifier ?
Ah si Christ a tout fait
s'il a tout pardonné
donc je vais me livrer
au péché.
Quel est le problème ?
Nous serons devant
des indices complets.
Déjà les chrétiens
même si l'Élie
qui s'oppose
à ça
n'arrive pas à le faire.
Et la réalité
c'est que selon
la description biblique
c'est que Dieu
nous a justifiés
notamment pour nous rendre justes
pour faire d'un
de ses enfants
et la discussion ici
n'est pas par rapport
à ce que nous pouvons faire
même pas
ce que nous allons faire
pour être plus assurés
de la foi.
La question c'est
l'observation des lettres
c'est un constat
soit nous sommes héritiers
de Dieu
soit nous ne le sommes pas
car c'est impossible
que celui qui a été
déclaré juste
et pardonné
ne manifeste pas
la vie de Dieu en lui
car Dieu
les a déclarés justes
notamment pour les grèves
et voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul les dit
ouvertement
et clairement
et volontairement
c'est plus moi
qui vis
c'est Christ qui vit en moi.
Je suis mort
par la loi
pour moi-même
afin de vivre
pour Dieu.
Vous voyez ?
Donc à nous
ce n'est pas
la question
de nous demander
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
pour être sûr
qu'on est sauvé
c'est plutôt
qu'est-ce qu'on doit observer
en tant qu'une nouvelle nature
en tant qu'évidence
pour être rassuré
que nous sommes sauvés
et c'est de cette manière
que Paul va corriger.
Et donc
ces prétextes
à la chair
l'apôtre Paul
est en train d'exhorter
les galates
par rapport à ça
et donc
c'est la lettre
qui nous donne
les plus d'informations
pour ce qui concerne
l'essence
et la notion
d'être justifié
par la foi
mais c'est aussi
la lettre
qui nous donne
les plus d'informations
avec clarté
sur les fonctionnements
de la sanctification
et c'est urgent
que l'Église restaure
cette compréhension
aujourd'hui.
S'il y a
une doctrine
qui semble être
je ne dirais pas
la plus attaquée
mais la plus mal comprise
l'une des plus mal comprises
dans la génération
c'est comment
la sanctification
fonctionne
dans la vie
du chrétien
et donc
l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire
c'est inséparable
l'œuvre de la justification
de l'œuvre
de la sanctification
et c'est intéressant
car par la correction
de la compréhension
du fonctionnement
de la sanctification
pour plus dur
qu'il soit
la lettre
aux galates
c'est la lettre
la plus dure
du Nouveau Testament
c'est une lettre
qui ne commence pas
avec les salutations
commence directement
avec des reproches
et il y a des mots
très durs
et on comprend par là
qu'heureusement
qu'elle a été faite
de cette manière
car ça c'est une preuve
redoublée du fait
que là où
le Saint-Esprit est
même si
les chrétiens
peuvent aller très loin
dans des moments
ponctuels dans leur vie
qu'ils puissent être
dans la déroute
la plus menaçante
ils étaient au bord
de ces fers
qui concitent
et d'être déclarés
anathèmes
mais on n'a pas
une deuxième lettre
aux galates
c'est un fort indice
selon les commentaristes
qui eux
ils se sont laissés
corriger par le Saint-Esprit
c'est un fort indice
de la persévérance
des saints
de l'efficacité
irrésistible
de Saint-Esprit
dans la vie
du vrai croyant
ce qui doit
nous faire
nous rendre
diligents
par rapport
à la recherche
des évidences
du Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
mais qui nous empêche
au même temps
de juger
un chrétien
authentique
par les pires
moments de sa vie
s'il est en train
de traverser
sa saison
la moins
fructifère
où il a cédé
aux appels
de la chair
c'est par
l'ensemble
de sa vie
que nous allons
évaluer
si cette personne
est véritablement
chrétien
ou non
et particulièrement
par la manière
dont
le Saint-Esprit
a réussi
à les réprocher
à les corriger
à les redresser
à les restaurer
et donc
lorsque l'apôtre Paul
va apporter
la correction
c'est très important
pour nous
de voir
la relation
entre
la compréhension
de notre nouvelle nature
les fonctionnements
de la sainteté
et l'efficacité
de la sanctification
dans nos vies
c'est très important
la conception
qui veut vous proposer
que la sanctification
c'est de vous
fermer dans une chambre
et prier
contre vos péchés
jusqu'à ce qu'une bénédiction
sanctificatrice
arrive
n'est pas biblique
bien sûr
que la prière
fait partie
du travail
mais il y a
beaucoup
d'autres aspects
du fonctionnement
de la sanctification
qui doit nous pousser
à être plus diligents
à plusieurs égards
voilà pourquoi
nous ne sommes pas
devant
tous les temps
des impératifs
qui nous dirigent
à prier
ce sont des impératifs
qui nous appellent
à changer
tout simplement
et qui peut supporter
ces impératifs
c'est les saint-esprit
qui habitent
nous
qui pourvoient la force
pour soumonter
ces problèmes
et donc d'un côté
on a
cette conception
des bénédictions
qui devient fataliste
la sanctification
est une bénédiction
et la personne
le plus elle prie
le plus elle va
renforcer l'idée
de la bataille
elle va donner
plus d'attention
aux problèmes
de la chair
qui sont déjà
très fréquents
dans sa vie
qu'elle s'est concentrée
sur les choses
qui auraient pu
la délivrer
de cette condition
et le plus
la personne
ne réussit pas
tout simplement
par la prière
à surmonter
en péché
elle peut tomber
dans des péchés
très graves
en se disant
Dieu m'a abandonné
Dieu n'est pas
en train de m'aider
dès que je ne ressens pas
cette facilité
miraculeuse
à me délivrer
d'un péché
c'est car il n'y a
plus de chance
pour moi
il peut même
douter de son salut
parce que des fois
c'est juste qu'il n'est pas
en train de faire
la bataille
comme il faut
de l'autre côté
il y a cette performance
légaliste
où on essaie
de terrifier la personne
tu vas perdre ton salut
donc vas-y
travaille
fais des efforts
si ton problème
est avec l'argent
donne tout à l'église
si ton problème
est avec la sexualité
mettez des vêtements
qui vont couvrir
presque comme
les musulmans
tous les corps
c'est comme cette blague
qui est racontée
où un pasteur
rencontre un prêtre
depuis
après plusieurs ans
des séparations
et les prêtres
étaient dans
un monastère
et ils viennent
vers les pasteurs
et disent
tu sais
ça fait déjà
dix ans
que je ne vois
même pas
une femme
réponse du pasteur
et voilà
que tu ne penses
à autre chose
c'est pas
de manière externe
qu'on va traiter
ces problèmes
pour plus
que ça soit aussi
sage
d'éviter
l'exposition
à la tentation
à plusieurs égards
mais la réalité
qui nous voit ici
c'est que
la performance
légaliste
n'a jamais eu
la capacité
de surmonter
les péchés
et bien sûr
que les prétextes
libertants
qui a aussi pratiqué
à plusieurs églises
encore aujourd'hui
mènent les églises
à la libertinage
en disant
Christ pardonne tout
donc on peut
rebaisser les paramètres
de la sainteté
et permettre
une liberté charnelle
aucune de ces conceptions
de sanctification
n'est la bonne
donc il faut
qu'on comprenne
comment marche
la sanctification
chez les chrétiens
comment marche
sa nature
et c'est ce que
l'apôtre Paul fait
ce qu'il fait
au verset 16
c'est démontrer
la nature essentielle
du nouveau-né
et de la sanctification
la vie chrétienne
est une bataille
des volontés
il dit
je dis donc
marchez selon l'esprit
et vous n'accomplirez pas
les désirs de la chair
la vraie liberté chrétienne
c'est lorsque
la volonté
de régénérer
prédominante
du nouveau-né
s'accorde
aux influences
de son esprit
donc la liberté
c'est de pouvoir
volontairement être
ce qui nous avons
été créés pour être
être l'image des dieux
être un enfant des dieux
vivre cette belle vie
des perfections
que l'Écrit
sa vie
a vécue
même si nous n'allons pas
aboutir à la perfection
encore dans cette vie
nous allons progresser
envers elle
prendre plaisir
dans elle
et c'est ça qui satisfait
notre ambition
sainte
de l'être régénéré
donc au verset 16
il dit
marchez selon l'esprit
et vous accomplirez
n'accomplirez pas
ou vous n'accomplirez
point
les désirs de la chair
ou n'accomplirez
jamais
les désirs de la chair
donc ici nous ne sommes pas
devant la perfection
car il y a une chair
qui fait encore appel
il y a encore les restes
de la chair
qui joue contre
notre sanctification
contre notre nouvelle volonté
contre l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
en nous
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer au verset 24
qui Paul va dire
ceux qui sont Jésus-Christ
ont crucifié la chair
avec ses passions
donc la vision
de la chair
c'est quelque chose
qui a été crucifié
qui a reçu un coup mortel
qui est encore
en train de mourir
donc se manifester
de faire appel à nous
et donc là
c'est quelque chose
qui nous appartient
la chair ici
c'est notre responsabilité
c'est notre contribution
au salut
nos péchés
et la réalité
c'est que c'est possible
par l'esprit
n'est pas satisfaire
ses désirs
rien que les désirs
sont déjà pécheurs
c'est déjà un péché
les Christens
le sait ça clairement
mais nous pouvons
ne pas permettre
que ses désirs
se développent
et qu'ils soient
consommés
donc comment nous devons
et nous pouvons
ne pas satisfaire
les désirs de la chair
c'est d'abord
par la compréhension
que la vie chrétienne
est une bataille
et ça
c'est un trouble
pour la psychanalyse
pour la psychiatrie
pour la psychologie
car la crise
tous les êtres humains
expérimentent
dans une certaine mesure
les chrétiens
sont les seuls
qui arrivent
à surmonter
mais tous les êtres humains
ont une conscience
mais si les chrétiens
ne comprennent pas
la description
devant laquelle nous sommes
il peut parfois
penser qu'il n'est pas sauvé
il sait encore
les appels de la chair
douter de son salut
et donc la question
c'est pas
si la chair
se manifeste
de temps en temps
ou non
ou même constamment
avec certaines mesures
ma question c'est
quelle est la volonté
prédominante
quelle est
l'influence
victorieuse
à long terme
sur ma vie
je progresse
après ma conversion
plus envers
la scientification
où ma vie
est marquée
par les œuvres
de la chair
et donc
c'est une bataille réelle
on n'est pas
devant un être
schizophrénique
on est devant un être
qui a les restes
de sa nature ancienne
qui essaye
de lutter
contrairement
ce qu'il dit
verset 17
car la chair
a des désirs
contraires
à l'esprit
l'esprit
en a des contraires
à ceux de la chair
ils sont opposés
entre eux
afin qu'ils vous
n'effaciez
ce que vous voudriez
ce que nous voulons
c'est de faire
la volonté
de Dieu
avec l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
voilà pourquoi
verset 18
il dit
si vous êtes
conduits
par l'esprit
vous n'êtes
point
sous la loi
et donc
les chrétiens
ils vivent en bataille
avec
une victoire assurée
car l'influence
prédominante sur lui
c'est la troisième
personne toute puissante
de la Trinité
c'est impossible
que la chair
qui est crucifiée
en train de mourir
soit plus forte
chez les chrétiens
que l'esprit saint
mais ce que les chrétiens
doivent faire
dans cette bataille
c'est d'un côté
bien connaître
et résister
de manière
rapide
prompte
et radicalement
à l'ennemi
qui habite en nous
nous-mêmes
notre responsabilité
voilà pourquoi
Paul va présenter
les oeuvres de la chair
qu'on a déjà considérées
une par une
et la conception
de l'oeuvre de la chair
donc les oeuvres ici
c'est pour mettre
l'emphase sur le fait
que ça vient de nous-mêmes
ce sont des choses
que nous pouvons
produire de nous-mêmes
et c'est même
les résultats inévitables
même si nous
avec tous nos efforts légalistes
avec la loi
des dieux
nous essayons
d'accomplir
et Paul va dire
car
la loi est enferme
à cause du péché
qui est en nous
même les meilleurs
efforts
des personnes
non régénérées
envers la loi
ne vont qu'y produire
davantage
des tentations
et un comportement
légaliste
extérieur
superficiel
qui n'arrive
jamais au coeur
donc ils peuvent
avoir un comportement
externe
des apparatus
des systèmes
très lourds
qui semblent
beaucoup
à tous les objets
de l'Ancien Testament
quand on va dans
certaines églises évangéliques
plein d'éléments
de l'huile
ou de l'eau bénie
ou la rose
ou les campagnes
toutes ces performances
les dates
l'année
du ne sais pas quoi
avec un rapport
superficiel
envers ces choses
et le plus
on essaye
de
dissimuler
une espèce
de piété
le plus
les mêmes exigences
et la loi
provoquent
la tentation
en nous
c'est comme
disait l'apôtre Paul
et donc les œuvres
de la chair
sont manifestes
sont évidentes
tout le monde sait
qu'il s'agit
des péchés
et Paul
il est ici
en train d'appeler
péché
il n'est pas en train
d'appeler maladie
et nous avons vu
que chacun
de ces péchés
mentionnés
c'est pour nous rappeler
que si jamais
même en tant que chrétien
on retombe ponctuellement
dans un de ces péchés
c'est de notre faute
c'est de notre responsabilité
on a cédé
aux appels de la chair
on a méprisé
les influences
de son esprit
mais la pratique
constante
de ces choses
ne peuvent pas caractériser
un enfant des dieux
donc d'un côté
bien connaître
et résister
aux œuvres de la chair
et de l'autre côté
c'est ce qu'on va
introduire aujourd'hui
c'est de bien connaître
et cultiver
positivement
les fruits
de l'esprit
qui est aspiré
par ma nouvelle nature
et aspiré par
le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
et donc
la vie chrétienne
plutôt que
de penser
de manière
négative
penser que
la vie chrétienne
c'est de nous priver
d'un nombre
énorme
d'interdiction
des choses
qu'on ne doit pas faire
des soi-disant
plaisirs
de la vie
la réalité
c'est que
quelque part
nous
et Dieu
nous devrions être
est certainement
plus intéressé
à notre aspiration
pour une belle vie
pour une vie
qui porte
véritablement
la satisfaction
de nos âmes
il n'est pas
si préoccupé
même s'il est
bien sûr
préoccupé
car Christ a dû payer
pour tous ses péchés
avec ce que nous
ne devons pas faire
mais la vie
plus belle du chrétien
c'est celle
qui est plus concentrée
sur ce que nous
devons faire
pardonne-nous
de nos fautes commises
mais pardonne-nous
aussi Seigneur
de ne pas avoir
faire les biens
lorsqu'il s'est là
été à notre portée
donc l'obsession
du chrétien
c'est d'être
similaire à Dieu
à Christ
et donc
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénignité
la fidélité
la douceur
la tempérance
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
c'est-à-dire
l'essence de la loi
la signification
de la loi
c'était
de nous conduire
à la conviction
qui sait qui
Dieu attendait-nous
ce n'est pas un comportement
externe
qui cherche à obéir
ces lois
c'est d'avoir
un tel caractère
c'est d'être
un tel type
de personne
qui par sa nature
à l'image
de Dieu
ne peut pas produire
ces oeuvres
qui ont été évoquées
comme oeuvres
de la chair
de péché
donc les fruits de l'esprit
nous est présenté
et il dit
la loi
n'est pas contre ces choses
une personne
qui n'a pas la loi
mais qui a ces choses
n'a pas besoin de la loi
vous comprenez
pourquoi les Galactes
n'avaient pas forcément
besoin de la loi
et donc
on a déjà considéré
les oeuvres de la chair
nous sommes en train
de considérer
l'oeuvre du Saint-Esprit
ou plutôt
les fruits du Saint-Esprit
et l'objectif
de l'apôtre
il est clair
il est en train
de traiter
l'importance
que nous sommes
plus préoccupés
avec un constat
envers nos vies
une assurance
à propos de notre salut
si nous sommes
au nom ou non
des vrais enfants
des dieux
des vrais héritiers
donc plutôt que
de chercher
ce que nous devons faire
il est intéressé
à être sûr
que nous sommes sauvés
que les fruits de l'esprit
est présent
dans nos vies
voilà pourquoi
au verset 21
il a dit
ceux qui commettent
des telles choses
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui vivent
dans la pratique
des telles choses
des oeuvres de la chair
n'hériteront point
les règles des dieux
donc pourquoi
il a utilisé
intentionnellement
les mots
héritage
est lié
à la conception
des promesses
et pas
à la conception
des conquêtes
et héritage
est lié
à la conception
des filiations
aussi
donc ce qu'il est
en train de dire
c'est pas
faites des efforts
pour ne pas pratiquer
les oeuvres de la chair
afin de conquérir
les règles de dieux
par force
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est
soyez rassurés
qui vous êtes
enfant de la promesse
que vous avez placé
votre foi
en Jésus Christ
et par votre foi
en Christ
tout comme Abraham
qui a cru en Dieu
et cela lui a été
amputé par justice
que votre foi
est placée
dans les descendants
sanguliers
d'Abraham
Christ lui-même
car c'est
par notre union
à Christ
spirituel
vital
légal
que nous sommes
fait
enfant de Dieu
et si nous sommes
unis à Christ
par la foi
c'est clair
que la vie
des dieux
nous en tant
qu'enfant
des dieux
héritiers
nous allons
manifester
ces fruits
c'est une question
des constats
d'intérêt
pour nous
c'est une
auto-évaluation
qui cherche
à contempler
la présence
du fruit
du Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
car une fois
que nous sommes
rassurés
de la présence
du fruit
de l'Esprit
dans nos vies
nous pouvons
être rassurés
de la persévérance
des saints
que cette sémence
ne s'éphone pas
que c'est
les gages
d'un héritage
l'objectif
d'un gage
c'est de nous assurer
qu'il ne sera jamais
révoqué
que la promesse
va s'accomplir
pleinement
et donc
la vérité centrale
ici mentionnée
c'est que
les fruits
de l'Esprit
est une évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour identifier
un vrai
héritier
du royaume
des dieux
et mon intérêt
aujourd'hui
c'est juste
d'introduire
cette vérité
centrale
les fruits
de l'Esprit
est une évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour identifier
un vrai
héritier
du royaume
des dieux
c'est une évidence
avant tout
nécessaire
car
elle est mise
et introduite
avec un mais
qui a une fonction
des contrastes
adversatifs
et là on a
au verset 19
or
les oeuvres
de la chair
sont
manifestes
quel est
l'objectif
de l'apôtre Paul
lorsqu'il dit
elles sont
manifestes
c'est qu'une personne
qui n'est pas
régénérée
aura
sa vie
marquée
pour plus qu'il puisse
être un hypocrite
pendant 16 ans
sa vie sera
prédominamment
marquée
par la pratique
constante
des oeuvres
de la chair
vous êtes avec moi
elles sont
manifestes
un non-chrétien
ne peut pas
s'empêcher
de ne pas
manifester
les oeuvres
de la chair
vous êtes avec moi
et donc
les contrastes
ici
il est très clair
il veut dire
que tout comme
les oeuvres
de la chair
sont manifestes
chez les non-chrétiens
et ce sont
les évidences
qui nous donnent
des indices
qui ne sont pas
régénérés
pour plus religieux
qu'ils les soient
et de l'autre côté
il va présenter
les fruits
de l'esprit
quel est l'intérêt
c'est de démontrer
que c'est impossible
à un arbre
qui possède
une telle nature
de ne pas
porter
ou rendre
évident
son fruit
l'arbre
nous révèle
sa nature
au partir du moment
où elle
présente son fruit
ayant pour
racine
de la nouvelle
vie spirituelle
Christ lui-même
il a les cèpes
auxquelles
nous sommes greffés
les fruits
qui produira
cet arbre
attention
si nous sommes
vraiment chrétiens
nous ne sommes
qu'une branche
quelle est la proportion
de l'influence
déterminante
qu'on aurait pu avoir
envers les fruits
qu'on va porter
même si les restes
de la chair
qui sont en train
de mourir
font appel
et qu'on essaye
de résister
c'est très moche
et ça arrive
et qui par nos efforts
personnels
on finisse
pour produire
un petit fruit
de la chair
c'est clair
que la sève
prédominante
qui coule
dans nos vies
vient d'un arbre
dont la santé
est infiniment parfaite
et c'est impossible
que les fruits
prédominants
de ces petites branches
qui nous sommes
greffés à Christ
ne soient
les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
donc c'est
évident
c'est évident
pour les chrétiens
et là à nouveau
bien sûr
nous pouvons avoir
nos moments
d'oscillation
et ça peut
nous décourager
énormément
mais si
à un moment donné
dans notre vie
dans les passés
on était
suffisamment
rassurés
que le Saint-Esprit
a agi en nous
de cette manière
comme nous les verrons
si nous ne le doutons pas
en fait
qu'on produisait
de manière très organique
et naturelle
par l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
et des fruits
de l'esprit
nous pouvons avoir
une forte espérance
vers les futurs
que ça va
revenir
et donc c'est déjà
une évidence
on n'a pas la capacité
de cacher Dieu
si nous sommes
habitation
du Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
déjà
on ne peut
ne pas percevoir
voilà pourquoi
la théorie
de certaines conversions
où la personne
n'a aucune conscience
de la présence
ou de l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
dans sa vie
doit être mise en question
c'est une personne
qui vient habiter en nous
et qui a une interaction
avec nous
avec une influence
personnelle
affective
et donc
c'est une évidence
qui se manifeste
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est-à-dire
les caractères
de chrétien
sera marqué
par ses vertus
par ses facettes
qui sont là
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénédité
la fidélité
la douceur
la tempérance
c'est aussi
une évidence
nécessaire
que les croyants
attention
et que tous les croyants
doivent nécessairement
pour se considérer
comme tel
pour être
identifiés
comme tel
ils doivent présenter
cette évidence
pourquoi
car sans le Saint-Esprit
personne ne peut
produire
ses fruits
c'est les fruits
de l'esprit
ah mais moi
je lis ces mots-là
et je vois des amis
non-chrétiens
qui sont des bonnes gens
et sympas
l'enfer sera rempli
des personnes sympas
on a plus à être
la réalité
à propos
de ces termes
c'est de comprendre
ces termes
pour plus qu'ils
puissent avoir
quelques intersections
avec une dimension
très superficielle
et humaine
des joies
nous sommes devant
la conception divine
une conception spirituelle
surnaturelle
et ces termes
donc la joie
qui expérimente
les chrétiens
un non-chrétien
ne peut pas
expérimenter
les types
des paix
qui expérimentent
les chrétiens
pas pour un seul second
un non-chrétien
n'a jamais expérimenté
nous sommes dans la génération
de la syndrome nipponique
et la syndrome nipponique
je veux dire
est cohérente
avec l'état
du monde païen
nous sommes fragiles
nous n'avons pas
les contrôles
des circonstances
nous sommes dans un monde
qui a souffert la chute
donc il y a plein
des menaces
contre nous-mêmes
des maladies
des guerres
très cohérents
avec le non-chrétien
sauf que
c'est lui
qui a converti
il a compris
qu'il a été fait
enfant des dieux
les dieux
qui gouvernent
chaque attente
de l'univers
en faveur
de son peuple
et donc
toutes ces vertus
comme on verra plus tard
ne peuvent pas être
comprises tout simplement
comme des vertus
accessibles à l'effort
au mans
ou présentes
dans les personnes
qui ont tout simplement
un tempérament pacifique
et à la fin de compte
c'est
on va découvrir
que cette personne
elle a juste
elle a peur
d'être dans des disputes
c'est pas un pacificateur
c'est parfois
un lâche
tout simplement
et donc
elles ne peuvent
qu'être reproduites
par les Saint-Esprit
il n'y a pas
de chrétien
sans le Saint-Esprit
si le Saint-Esprit
est présent
ils ne peuvent pas
l'empêcher
d'afficher
donc c'est nécessaire
ici
c'est une évidence
universelle
pour tous les croyants
c'est nécessaire
pour considérer
quelqu'un
ou nous considérer
comme chrétien
qui ont né
ses fruits
ici nous ne sommes pas
devant les dons
du Saint-Esprit
eux ils ne sont pas
universels
le Saint-Esprit
pour accomplir
certaines fonctions
dans les corps du Christ
il va nous donner
des dons différents
pour exercer
dans les corps du Christ
et c'est dommage
la confusion faite
entre parfois
la réception des dons
et la grâce
de la sanctification
en disant
car il parle en langue
il a reçu
cette bénédiction
spéciale
du Saint-Esprit
qui fait de lui
plus sang
et plus important
que les autres
et on va lire
la lettre
deux lettres
avec
les réproches
qui arrivent
les plus proches
des réproches
des Galates
deux lettres
en disant
qu'ils sont encore
charnels
malgré tous les dons
spirituels
qu'ils se servaient
pour s'enorgueillir
c'est ce qui a fait
Jonathan Edwards
qui a traversé
deux grands réveils
très importants
dans sa vie
dans son ministère
à écrire son livre
les affections religieuses
les vrais fruits
du Saint-Esprit
et là il dit
par l'extérieur
tout simplement
c'est difficile
de dire
si un don
est légitime
ou non
mais nous pouvons
être sûrs
que là
où le Saint-Esprit
porte un réveil
et ses faits présents
c'est pas forcément
par l'usage
des dons
que nous allons
contempler sa présence
mais par la transformation
et les influences
qu'il porte
par les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
c'est très important
pour nous
de considérer
que les dons
sont variés
et nous pouvons
même gérer
les dons
de manière
très impie
être fortement
réprochés
par le Saint-Esprit
mais ici
les fruits
il faut qu'ils soient
présents
chez tous les chrétiens
car c'est une question
de caractère
c'est une question
de la personne
des dieux
se manifestant en nous
en formant en nous
sa personne
c'est une question
de savoir
que nous sommes devant
les mêmes traitements
qu'on reçoit
du caractère parfait
des dieux
et qu'il veut
qu'on reproduise
dans nos vies
c'est comme ça
qu'on considère
ces facettes
donc il est nécessaire
il est aussi suffisant
ce n'est pas
la seule
preuve
des conversions
mais c'est une preuve
suffisante
des conversions
si nous comprenons
les dons de l'esprit
pardon
les fruits
de l'esprit
comme un étant
interprété
de manière correcte
de manière spirituelle
pas des vertus
humaine
car dans
le raisonnement
de l'apôtre Paul
lui-même
en Galate
il nous prépare
à chaque fois
pour présenter
les saints esprits
comme
les dons
des dieux
les plus conditionnés
à l'accomplissement
de l'oeuvre du Christ
voilà pourquoi
c'est un pentecôte
qu'on a
cette nouvelle
alliance inaugurée
les saints esprits
descendus
comme en étant
la bénédiction
suprême
qui va
opérer
toutes les promesses
grandieuses
de la nouvelle alliance
la loi des dieux
inscrite dans nos cœurs
Dieu qui habite
en nous
nous sommes désormais
les pierres vivantes
avec ces tabernacles
qui est formé par Dieu
par la communauté
où les saints esprits
viennent habiter
et donc si
la condition
suprême
a été requise
pour que les saints esprits
soient donnés
et la condition suprême
a été Christ
qui pourra
supprimer
les saints esprits
de la vie d'un croyant
qu'est-ce qui manquerait
pour nous
pour maintenir
les saints esprits
pour mériter
ça dépend
exclusivement
de l'oeuvre
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
il l'a accompli
parfaitement
et la question c'est
est-ce que j'ai déjà
reçu les saints esprits
ou non
et voilà pourquoi
si nous sommes
devant des preuves
évidentes
d'une personne
qui dans la plupart
de sa vie
qui dans l'ensemble
a démontré
avoir reçu
les fruits
authentiques
de son esprit
c'est suffisant
pour que son assurance
de salut
soit bien présente
qu'il est suffisant
même si l'intensité
de cette manifestation
entre nous
peut varier
et donc il est nécessaire
et suffisant
pour identifier
un vrai
héritier
du roi
de Dieu
donc la question ici
c'est pas tout simplement
la manifestation
de certaines vertus
c'est plutôt
la manifestation
du caractère
du vrai héritier
du vrai enfant
c'est-à-dire
devant un chrétien
nous sommes devant
un péléran
une personne
qui touche légèrement
aux discussions politiques
de ce monde-là
car on sait
que ça ne va pas
venir de la politique
l'harmonie globale
il ne va pas mépriser
l'importance
de ces choses
il sera un bon citoyen
lorsqu'il traversera
la terre
mais c'est clair
que ses affections
son espoir
sa patrie
ses valeurs
se trouvent
dans les cieux
il est un héritier
du roi
de Dieu
et en tant qu'héritier
il est aussi un enfant
donc ici nous sommes
devant la description
des éléments
composants
qui ne sont pas exhaustifs
mais des éléments
principaux
qui composent
ces caractères
spirituels
que Dieu
va générer en nous
donc à partir
du dimanche prochain
nous allons nous
approfondir
dans la compréhension
de la nature
et du fonctionnement
essentiel
du fruit de l'esprit
c'est un fruit
organique
spirituel
indivisible
permanent
et cultivable
et nous devons apprendre
que c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit cultiver
même si ce n'est pas nous
qui sommes les plus déterminants
pour la production du fruit
et ensuite
on va traiter
chacune de ces facettes
pour bien comprendre
ce qui est l'amour
issu du fruit de l'esprit
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
nous sommes devant
plutôt un caractère
spirituel
la personne de Dieu
formée en nous
Christ lui-même
s'est manifestant
dans nos vies
que d'être tout simplement
en train de considérer
ce qu'on aurait pu produire
c'est le ministère
principal
de son esprit
les dons sont
bien secondaires
même si importants
comparés
aux fruits de l'esprit
on va